now he's taken his talents to the
broadway stage thank you mr williams
he's earned a tony nomination for his
broadway debut that's hard to do
williams plays darren lemming a major
league baseball player in the show it's
called take me out in this scene he
talks with his teammate kippy about
coming out
gibby this seems to be a bigger event in
your life than it is in mind i'm just so
happy for you there because now you're
gonna be happy well i've always been
happy but now you'll be completely happy
you've named yourself darren you have
put yourself into words which means
you're free in a way that you've never
been before
okay and of course there'll be the
inevitable difficult period i don't
think that
what i don't think there'll be a
difficult period
well
there's inevitably a difficult period
yeah maybe if it was somebody else but i
don't see it
sort of stuff going on with the guys now
but i don't take note of that i can just
ride above
that so confident jesse williams joins
us now good morning to you good morning
i was there tuesday night
cg113 did you see that i'm so glad i
didn't know i've decided i don't want to
know when people are there oh you don't
want it yeah it just adds
another level awareness i i get that i
get that
you didn't hear me go jesse
that was very clever it was you the guy
escorted out
that was me
but i've read that you said that you
wanted something that was insurmountable
that was terrifying that was extremely
difficult yeah why did you why did you
want that and why was this it for you
this was definitely it for me i think um
i wanted to get out of my comfort zone
you know i want i'd been somewhere where
i got very comfortable i was able you
know for a variety of reasons um you
know i was on that show for a long time
able to raise my children be close it's
all very kind of i know where i am it's
very predictable nothing's going to be
earth-shattering and um i wanted to do
something next that was absolutely scary
and got me a little uncomfortable
challenged me um
put me in a place to uh reshape what
scared you about it jessica well a
couple things i mean
it's live yeah it's back
it's an audience right there you're live
you're on the tight rope you're on the
high wire and um so you have to be in
you have to be present
you have to be present uh it can change
there it can change every show every
minute every audience is different um
and you also there there's a freedom
through repetition you know on tv and
film you do you say a line once and
you'll never say it again in your life
yeah this is the opposite you get to
really explore every look and cranny of
and every nuance as we were talking
about earlier of of that that person's
life and experience so um there's a lot
there's it's a liberating it's a
liberating thing you feel very much
alive and news flash in case there are
those that don't know
there's a little bit of nudity a little
bit just a little bit that's the word we
like to use yeah it's not a little bit
look and i'm not complaining i'm not
complaining no no but but i i would
imagine but it's not gratuitous right
say that no but that was a big certainly
that was scary certainly that was
something you know if that's what you're
asking like when i first heard about the
play you know
people use shorthand right so there's uh
there's nudity it's baseball gay right
okay i'm certainly not gonna be naked on
stage that's no no thank you and then i
read it and then it was too late once i
read it i was hooked richard greenberg
is an absolutely spectacular writer and
i didn't have a choice it really wasn't
a decision to make it's smart it's on
the bleeding edge it's relevant um it's
got incredible incredibly dense comedy
and drama and pain and anguish there is
a real arc as an actor you look for an
arc you look for a challenge there are
very interesting characters that you can
play there are there are also situations
you can play that you're experiencing
something very interesting and this
character goes through an absolute
whirlwind and that is a very difficult
thing to do eight times a week
emotionally emotionally it's really
actually quite devastating which i
didn't anticipate to this degree right
you can you can read it you can rehearse
it but then living it your body doesn't
know the difference you know the you
know without giving too much away this
character goes through a great deal of
um pain
[Music]
so so that's that's a little difficult
to sustain over time i was gonna say
almost how do you handle that because
especially thinking of a day with a
matinee yeah you gotta get back up and
go back for a new audience yeah i'm i'm
still i'm always still figuring it out
but you certainly have a meditation
practice i figure out how to ground
myself afterwards kind of put some of
that away
um and we have such a great group of
folks that we're working with my
teammates are incredible uh so we rely
on each other and look this is my first
time doing a three-act play first time
uh is certainly on stage on broadway so
i'm always asking questions i'm always
looking for best practices best ideas
from anybody i'm a student really i'm
just just kind of happy to be here but
i'm fascinated by it jesse because it is
i've never seen anything like it on
stage and there's a massive shower scene
so all of the actors on stage are nude
and when it's first revealed i always
look to see what's the audience no one
reacts
and i'm surprised that there's no
tittering yeah snickering there's no
whoo there's none of that yeah i find
that and does that does that surprise
you because listen i have to be very
honest i went with my nephew you know
when he's sitting there he's drooling
behind his mask my glasses start fogging
because i was breathing so hard so i was
looking because it really is beautifully
beautifully done yeah but the audience
just sort of takes it all in
that first time you did it what did you
have expectations i think i did have an
expectation that there would be
some some
uh vocalization yeah vocalization people
in their discomfort we make sounds
just to try to and also the audience is
part of the play you know this thing is
you all react to each other you wonder
why she's laughing what the hell so
funny about that did i miss something
there's a lot of interactivity there
but that silence yes um it's really
interesting it is it does reflect some
maturity it does reflect also the reason
it's in the play is because it lets the
audience it forces the audience to
confront the situation that the
characters are confronting which is as
men
what is what is it to be a man
right how is it can i be a man without
being homophobic yes or is that how i
define what masculinity is by
demonstrating what i'm not and where do
i look how do i behave differently now
that there is somebody who's come out
that's present in my life and in these
characters lives now
we don't now we can't communicate our
masculinity through yeah certain
gestures or homophobia i have to look up
i have to make sure nothing can be
perceived differently that tension that
you feel is what the characters are
going going uh and they take our phones
but somebody there's always a jerk in
every audience took the picture and it
was released online and i thought it was
it i thought it was sad because it's
taken out of context did that make you
angry did that hurt your feelings or did
you just think okay you know i just kind
of
things happen with it you gotta i came
here on a mission i'm you know working
my plan and i've got to do a show and i
gotta do two shows and you just gotta
keep one foot in front of the other yeah
yeah but you know there's uh by and
large we're having we have a very kind
of uh sacred and wonderful um
interaction and there's terrific
audiences that are listening yes and
paying attention
thank you so much for coming in you can
see jesse and take me out on broadway at
second stages hayes theater until june
11th gotta hurry we'll be right back